ahora vamos a graficar los datos
experimentales de una reacción de primer
orden tenemos aquí la conversión de
ciclo propano a propano la cual es una
reacción de primer orden pero en el
inciso a nos piden que utilicemos los
datos experimentales para demostrar que
realmente es una reacción de primer
orden entonces pues nos vamos a fijar en
los datos experimentales y podemos
observar que conforme va aumentando el
tiempo por aquí tenemos la concentración
del ciclo propano en cada uno de estos
tiempos y podemos observar que va
decreciendo y eso es porque el ciclo
propano se está convirtiendo en propano
ahora para demostrar que si es una
reacción de primer orden vamos a
utilizar la ley de velocidad integrada
del vídeo pasado en el vídeo pasado
demostramos que si una reacción es de
primer orden
entonces el logaritmo natural de la
concentración del reactivo
en el tiempo t es igual a menos la
constante de velocidad por ese tiempo t
más el logaritmo natural de la
concentración del reactivo al tiempo
cero que la concentración inicial y en
realidad también funciona al revés si
una reacción cumple con esta ecuación
entonces es una reacción de primer orden
aunque hay entonces vamos a ver si estos
datos indican que la concentración del
ciclo propano satisface esta ecuación en
esta reacción a es el ciclo propano y
entonces esta ecuación la ley de la
velocidad integrada es el logaritmo
natural de el ciclo propano en el tiempo
t igual a menos la constante de
velocidad por el tiempo más el logaritmo
natural de la concentración inicial del
ciclo propano vamos a mover esto un poco
para acá como dijimos en el vídeo pasado
esto tiene la estructura de una
este es y es igual a este es x
esta es la pendiente y esta es la
ordenada al origen aquí lo que tenemos
es la ecuación de una recta marca
entonces si colocamos el logaritmo
natural de la concentración del ciclo
propano en el eje de las 10 y colocamos
al tiempo en el eje de las x gráfica mos
estos datos experimentales y lo que
obtenemos es una recta entonces sabemos
que si es una reacción de primer orden y
además sabemos que la constante de
velocidad es igual a la pendiente de esa
recta y también que la ordenada al
origen de esa recta es igual a logaritmo
natural de la concentración inicial del
ciclo propano
entonces pues vamos a graficar aunque
hay que tener cuidado aquí porque en
esta ecuación tenemos el logaritmo
natural de la concentración del ciclo
y aquí en los datos tenemos simplemente
la concentración del ciclo propano
entonces vamos a tener que sacar la
calculadora para calcular el logaritmo
natural
que hay en el primer tiempo tenemos una
concentración de 0.09 9 y queremos sacar
el logaritmo natural menos 2.31
- 2.31 y ahora sacamos el logaritmo
natural de 0 0 70 y 90 punto 0 79
logaritmo natural eso es menos 2.54 ok
menos 2.54
punto 0 65 logaritmo natural menos dos
puntos 73 menos 2 puntos 73 y finalmente
punto 0 54 logaritmo natural y eso es
menos 2 puntos 92 menos 2 puntos 92 ya
tenemos el logaritmo natural de la
concentración de ciclo propano en cada
uno de estos tiempos y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es graficar el logaritmo
natural de las concentraciones con
respecto al tiempo que hoy vamos a poner
a este en el eje h y al tiempo en el eje
x vamos para abajo en este eje tenemos
el tiempo en segundos y en el eje ya
tenemos a logaritmo natural de la
concentración del ciclo propano y vamos
a graficar estos puntos ok al tiempo
cero el ciclo propano tiene una
concentración de cero puntos 0 99 y él
y eso es menos 2.31 entonces nos vamos
por aquí tenemos aquí el menos 2 éste es
menos 2.1 menos 2.2 y menos 2.3 entonces
menos 2.31 debe de estar por aquí luego
300 segundos después el logaritmo
natural de la concentración del ciclo
propano es de menos 2.54 así es que nos
vamos al tiempo 300 y buscamos menos
2.54 menos 2.5 estado por aquí entonces
menos 2.54 debe de estar por aquí
ahora vamos al tiempo 600 en donde el
logaritmo natural de la concentración
del ciclo o propano es menos 2 puntos 73
menos 2.50 menos 2 puntos 60 menos 2
puntos 70 menos 2 puntos 73 más o menos
por aquí
y finalmente al tiempo 900 logaritmo
natural de la concentración del ciclo
propano es menos 2.92 menos 2 punto 50
60 70 80 menos 2.90 y menos 2.92 más o
menos por aquí muy bien tenemos estos
cuatro datos experimentales en esta
gráfica ahora lo que queremos hacer es
ver si podemos hacer una línea recta que
pase muy cerca de estos cuatro puntos
que y vamos a empezar por aquí listo más
o menos si quedan alineados y entonces
como los datos experimentales se parecen
muchísimo a una línea recta podemos
decir que si es una reacción de primer
orden que grafica mos estos datos y
encontramos que forman casi una línea
recta y que tienen la forma de y igual a
mx b entonces si es una reacción de
primer orden
y ya terminamos con la parte a bueno
ahora vamos con la parte b y aquí lo que
queremos es calcular el valor de la
constante de velocidad o sea de acá
ahora como en el inciso anterior ya
demostramos que se trata de una reacción
de primer orden entonces es un hecho que
las concentraciones del ciclo propano
cumplen con esta ecuación y por lo tanto
menos la constante de velocidad es la
pendiente de la recta que forman estos
datos así es que si calculamos la
pendiente de esta recta calculamos la
constante de velocidad y eso es justo lo
que vamos a hacer
la pendiente de esta recta es igual a
menos la constante de velocidad y hay
varias formas de calcular está pendiente
una de ellas es tomar dos puntos en esta
recta dos de estos datos experimentales
y calcular el cambio en el eje de las
leyes y dividirlo entre el cambio en el
eje de las equis y eso es igual a la
pendiente podemos por ejemplo escoger
estos dos puntos y calcular el cambio en
el eje de las che y lo dividimos entre
el cambio en el eje de las equis y eso
nos da la pendiente de la recta y
entonces las unidades de acá son de uno
en tres segundos
porque la ley de velocidad de la
reacción es igual acá por la
concentración del reactivo elevado a la
potencia 1 porque es una reacción de
primer orden la velocidad de la reacción
se mide en molares por segundo y la
concentración del ciclo
se miden molares elevada a la potencia 1
y por aquí tenemos que entonces molares
se cancelan con molares y nos queda que
la unidad de acá es 1 entre segundos
ok entonces como estábamos viendo puedes
tomar dos puntos de la tabla de datos
calcular de esa forma la pendiente y
obtener un valor de acá pero hay que
notar que los datos experimentales no
siempre son exactos y entre más
información experimental tengamos más
nos vamos a acercar al verdadero valor
de la constante acá
entonces lo que queremos es utilizar
toda la información que tenemos aquí con
estos cuatro datos experimentales y para
encontrar la recta que mejor se acerca a
los cuatro puntos que tenemos aquí lo
que necesitamos es hacer una regresión
lineal que es realmente muy sencillo
aunque hay nada más tenemos que sacar
una hoja de cálculo como excel o pellets
colocar toda nuestra información
experimental en la tabla que tenemos por
aquí 0 300 600 y 900 en la columna del
tiempo y en la otra columna tenemos
todos los valores del logaritmo natural
de la concentración del ciclo propano en
el tiempo cero el logaritmo natural de
la concentración del ciclo propano es
menos 2.31 luego en el tiempo te iguala
300 tenemos esta concentración menos
2.54 en el tiempo 600 tenemos menos 2.73
menos 2.73 y finalmente en el tiempo 900
el tiempo 900 tenemos una concentración
de menos 2.92 menos 2.92 luego
seleccionamos todos nuestros datos de
hecho hasta podemos hacer una gráfica
más precisa de nuestros datos nos vamos
a insertar
gráfica dispersión y esto y listo
aquí está una gráfica más precisa de
nuestros datos experimentales y ahora
pues vamos a pedirle a nuestra hoja de
cálculo que nos diga cuál es la línea
recta que más se acerca a estos cuatro
puntos y para eso vamos a presentación a
análisis
queremos una línea de tendencia y en
realidad queremos una línea de tendencia
lineal pero para que nos diga la
ecuación exacta de esa línea vamos a
ponerle más opciones de línea de
tendencia le pedimos una línea de
tendencia lineal y que nos presente la
ecuación en el gráfico ok y listo ya
tenemos aquí la línea recta que más se
asemeja a todos nuestros datos
experimentales y nos dice que la línea
recta es igual a menos 0.000 7
- 2.32 entonces nuestra pendiente es
menos 0.000 7 ahora como podemos
observar la hoja de cálculo redondeo la
pendiente entonces si por ejemplo
queremos saber el número exacto nos
colocamos en una de estas celdas y vamos
a utilizar una función aquí nos están
preguntando qué es lo que queremos hacer
para proponernos una función que nos
sirva entonces nada más tenemos que
escribir regresión lineal y listo nos
proponen una estimación lineal que ay
queremos conocer la pendiente podemos
aceptar y nos preguntan cuáles son los
valores de y los valores de ye son los
del logaritmo natural de la
concentración o sea estos de aquí y los
valores de x son los tiempos o sea esta
columna de aquí y entonces esta función
nos dice de una forma más exacta cuál es
el valor de la pendiente que nos dice
que es menos cero
2000 67 en notación científica es 6.7
por 10 a la menos 4 cierto a ver vamos a
checar lo tenemos que pasar el punto 1 2
3 4 lugares a la derecha se me había
olvidado el menos
esta es la pendiente m que ya sabemos
que es igual a menos la constante de
velocidad que nos interesa así es que ya
podemos concluir que la constante de
velocidad
acá es igual a 6.7 por 10 a la menos 4 y
como habíamos visto por acá las unidades
son 1 entre segundos entonces ya
encontramos la constante de velocidad de
esta reacción ya terminamos con el
inciso b y bueno lo que hicimos en todo
el vídeo fue primero demostrar que la
reacción es una reacción de primer orden
graficando los datos experimentales y
observando que tenían la forma de una
línea recta y después calculamos el
valor de la constante de velocidad de
esta reacción encontrando la pendiente
de la línea recta que mejor se ajusta a
nuestros datos